non esistono i territori sistema
immunitario vitale e oggi andremo a fare
la nuova challenge foto che solo i geni
riusciranno a capire e risolvere
scopriremo se stiamo dj se sei un serio
anche tu lo scopriremo assieme ad
analizzare il varie foto e poi potrete
scrivere le risposte nei commenti in
contemporanea noi prima che noi diamo le
nostre risorse che mette meno
suggerimenti
lasciate un bel anche se volete altre
challenge come questa è prendere i pop
corn video tutto schermo e iniziamo
allora foto numero 1 cosa c'è che non va
in questa foto vi ho capito in che cosa
sono due fronte ad uno specchio si sono
sicuramente di fronte uno specchio
perché qua si vede riflesso procure
riflesso di questa ragazza per riflesso
di quest'altro esatto quindi se c'è uno
specchio a destra e uno specchio a
sinistra ci sono due specchi serie
perché qua dietro le si vede guardando
davanti è appunto perché c'è uno
specchio anche di qua aspetto di
profondità
anche se è l'unica smarter plausibile
anche se vi sembra comunque strada che
siano vecchie che l'altro specie stia
riflettendo l'immagine davanti su quello
specchio che il foto numero 2
quali sono le differenze tra la prima
foto alla seconda foto allora una cosa
che noto subito voi si rimettono il
numero del bus a 648 403 quindi una
differenza trovata poi l'orario è
diverso
2 mi sembra che è l'edificio più alto
qui solo destino no l'unico è online
peccato mi sembra davvero più alto
vediamo quali sono differenze noi
abbiamo trovato solo due
ho detto fin da subito no altezza quelle
perché mai campi l'altro vedi e quindi
diciamo che c'era qualcosa nell'aria è
il numero la nuvola allora aveva ragione
vitale per quella dell'esperimento
dell'illusione ottica dello specchio si
sono solo due ragazze e ci sono due
specchi da una parte all'altra come
questa illusione qua vedete sono solo
due le ragazze quella che si giro da una
parte destra cosa che si gira a sinistra
figli sono questione regolazione allora
altro non trovare sponsor in mezzo a
tutti questi minimi
addio
vediamo chi lo trova prima tra ambiente
fisso
no no io non so come l'ho trovato subito
costa perché gli occhi celesti quindi
l'ho notato subito scriveteli come
ritrovata dai dove qui bravo allora
scrivete nei commenti se lo avete
trovato 6 a destra e sinistra in alto e
basso ed è cosa vuol dire che siamo dei
geni finora no sono fortuna è stato l 1
3 o 4 1400 qua allora dobbiamo trovare
le differenze tra il primo dipinto
secondo traverso se non sbaglio queste
un dipinto di tali bellissimo allora
vediamo
io ho notato che qua se non sbaglio se
scende più giù e qual è il più dritto o
forse una mia impressione
cosa ne pensate nemmeno poi c'è qualcosa
qua in basso c'è un pallino ma non c'è
ovvero forse c'è più spazio tra la
finestra e il braccio e altri scritti i
commenti quali avete trovato non ne
vediamo altre vediamo uno era quel
pallino è andata allora in questa foto
c'è un qualcosa che è stato aggiunto
dopo ovest e rende o questo signore o
questa volta ho questa persona che sta
analizzando qualcosa secondo voi cosa è
stato aggiunto dopo io dico le renne
perché non sanno che secondo me
colore strano sulle corna vede che hanno
tanti ma anche erano anche il signore
dietro le renne vedo che c'è una parte
un po bianca guardando meglio anche la
volta malavolta mi sa che fa parte della
scena mentre invece è stato aggiunto io
dico che le uniche cose aggiunge sono i
cervi scrivetemi di come il così è stato
aggiunto secondo voi e poi dopo vediamo
la risposta allora abbiamo aggiunto un
po di dettagli a questo monumento quali
sono allora me sembra aggiunto questi
cavalli mi sembrano troppo i denti si
l'uno con l'altro
non so se ne sono stati aggiunti due o
uno tu cosa ne pensi
io penso che tutto il cielo dietro cioè
almeno il cielo con gli aerei sono stati
aggiunti dopo perché non mi sembra nel
cielo nella distanza dall aereo stato e
non mi sembra per niente e poi secondo
me si è stato aggiunto soprattutto le
due statue d'oro d'ora da lì mi sembra
che non c'entrano niente con i cavalli
no secondo me centro sia gli aerei
perché magari qualche manifestazione si
è arrestato e sono solo i cavalli
stranissimi perché sono identici quindi
secondo me o due o uno sono stati
aggiunti in ogni lato secondo voi
scrivete nei commenti allora qua si è
scritto che bisogna essere molto attenti
per capire cosa c'è di strano in questa
foto vediamo meglio io credo di averlo
già capito asi cavata
allora se il fotografo sta con i piedi
già nell'acqua mi apre invece gli sposi
sono coi piedi sopra l'acqua c'è
qualcosa che non va perché no noi
sardegna abbiamo delle spiagge così come
la pelosa in questo cammino i cambi di
cammini però è però vediamo arrivare
basta più profonda è qui dove c'è il
fotografo più profondo dove c'è
gli sposi invece sono più più no ma
succede anche quello e poi non lo so
questo futuro non mi sembra che sia
stato aggiunto dopo sembra super finto
infatti non ha senso neanche col
fotografo lì oppure immaginate solo i
gabbiani che sono da leggersi dott
scrivete secondo voi chi è stato
aggiunto cosa c'è di strano in questa
fuoco il todi hanno la stoffa pure super
strano certo se qualcuno che non c'entra
molto in questa foto chi è
beh sono tutte le pecore e poi al centro
ci sono tre capre notre guerra se non
altro ho visto forse proprio questa che
è stata aggiunta dopo perché è un po del
collo così riesce fuori scherzata dentro
irrisa quindi forse forse io dico questa
capra capra scrivete voi nei commenti
cosa è stato aggiunto dopo secondo voi
allora la foto originale
doveva essere una foto del ciclista o
della coppia dietro secondo voi scrivete
nei commenti
a me sembra ovvio che la foto deve
essere del ciclista pertanto 6 si vede
per niente bene però potrebbe essere che
il fotografo stava facendo la foto la
coppia e poi è passato è passato il
ciclista e mentre cliccava il fuoco è
stato preso sul ciclista invece che
sulla coppia eh no non penso proprio
perché non so che copia si metterebbe
imposta così lontano da scorta dei fiori
no direi che secondo me la foto
del ct della selecao a due elementi che
sono stati modificati
il primo è molto semplice è il secondo
sarà più facile da capire per le persone
che conoscono bene la gioconda insomma
allora il primo l'ho già visto sicuro al
cento per cento il secondo
tu hai visto qualcosa adesso per eni
come se avete mai visto la gioconda dal
vivo a parigi al louvre
io mi ricordo che mi aspettavo un quadro
e loro manifesto fantastico tra l'altro
è messa in una stanza solo per lei
e poi vedi un quadretto di corsa in
tutte le gente accalcata davanti si dona
sete fame è quello venezia o dimostra la
prima cosa sicuramente sono gli occhi
perché la gioconda non ha gli occhi
verdi azzurri giorni proprio visto
perché sei tal petta voi la seconda cosa
mi viene in mente una cosa però mi
sembra strano che non mi ricordavo che
avessi una scollatura così adrian
diciamo non lo so forse le hanno fatto
una scollatura più grande forno
no non riesco a vedere l'altro dettaglio
che è stato modificato scrivete voi nei
commenti secondo voi cosa hanno
modificato guidiamo la prossima foto
sì ora bisogna trovare il panna vediamo
il panda sì ma quali sono i vescovi devi
trovare risponda scrivete se l'avete
trovato
e difficile ma l'ho visto l'ho visto la
luce degli occhi di fuori a stare bene
bene troppi no non lo vedo proprio che
arredi maybach voi scrivetelo nei
commenti ora vi dico io dove l'ho visto
che c'è ma gli affitti per sbaglio
nessuno se n'è accorto sicuramente in
mezzo due vescovi a ecco le risposte
allora l'unica che è stato aggiunto e lì
presente la volpe ma in primissimo piano
che vanno vagliate tutte come fa le
corna ad avere quel colore lì si passa
al riflesso è un riflesso della luce
ok anche perché una volta non si
avvicina così agli esseri umani
questo è vero allora avevo ragione io
anche se meno sicura se fossero due
cavalli che erano stati aggiunti o uno e
tutti gli emiliani stagion ora il
contrario 2 capito che l'italia non è un
genietto di sapere se l'avete indovinata
anche voi questa quindi due cavalli sono
stati aggiunti a ecco infatti ora sembra
più naturale professione
spazio anche transocean non troppo
attaccato fin qui abbiamo visto
l'aumento per niente mai avete detto il
pinguino non l'ho visto assolutamente
per il fotografo fin qui davvero
l'abbiamo beccata molto in guinea oggi
abbiamo detto che l'uccello da sopra
sembrava nato invece centra niente
gabbiano bendoni rado bene o male che
sarà più indovinata la capretta che
stava dietro se non c'entrava ecco lo
sapevo era troppo fin da quella coppia
cosa muovono un po copia privata era
stata fatta al ciclista voi avete il
dominatore scollature l'evento milano
finale se lo stesso la scollatura ma qua
l'hanno aumentata un pochino e si
l'originale molto bella mi rimane ero
accorto gorni degli occhi si beve che
sono inseriti pantaleo di prossimo lo
dobbiamo trovare tre differenze ora
l'autista 7 a ok sui una l'ho vista
anch'io perché proprio ovvia la seconda
a ok anche della seconda l'ho vista
manca la terza ok vitale fermo la prima
se voi avete trovato ridicola non fatemi
convinti ho visto anche la seconda che
dai che si arrivi a trovare la terza ai
gis e così 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 0 non
trovate solo due
ho provato allora la quota doppia del
sapere il bastone che esce dalla
matricola terza era stata prima seconda
e terza trova tre differenze ok una l'ho
trovata asi le altre storie difficili
addio 2 manca la terza ok una l'ho
trovata a matera la trovo la terza tanto
tanto
e davvero difficile tornata 61 bravo
tombe e dai dieci secondi 10 9 8 7 6 5 4
3 2 1
povero vittorio bo letto allora la prima
che trovato quale il bottone di bozza è
stata una mia terra si stimano mia prima
che sarebbe questo 4 che quando e quindi
la seconda qual è il numero 2 sulla
sveglia bravo e ora ti faccio vedere la
testa a terra nada
com'è stata la tua prima per me la prima
è stata l'orologio seconda la porta è
quella di base del bottone non la trova
roma tre differenze che orrore questa
pelliccia di orso
allora ho trovato due sì anch'io due
cornetti ma è sempre più difficile trova
non altro la terza è trovato che la
terza non ci credo ora 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
mappe
al 9 la prima che ho trovato è stato il
bottone anch'io
ok la seconda il bastone esatto comunque
il treno per hogwarts quindi dobbiamo
essere bravi perché l'abbiamo pure visto
dal vivo neuer e ora lo trovavo ora l'ho
trovato anch'io 2 ha trovato tre trovate
trovato 10 beta 7 6
vediamo 432
però ho trovato solo due allora mai
trovato
allora la prima che ho trovato questo
episodio pronta pronto sul marciapiede
con la seconda il fumo dalla non ci sia
accorta della più ovvia guarda qua i
numeri
ho visto prossima vediamo se questa
sembra difficile proprio tre differenze
61 trovato una l'ho trovata anch'io due
o tre no facciamo una trovata la terza
nel 92 lo so non lo trovo non c'è niente
no vabbè si sono sbagliati non è isolato
qualche porta cosa facciamo ci
arrendiamo tutte e due ma giammai
vabbè magari lo abbiamo scoperto le cose
vediamo allora l'orologio è la bella
prima poi la seconda il logo su quello e
quindi la testa non se vediamo la
risposta ce l'avevamo davanti agli occhi
che vi ho fatto come la sedia e ragazze
quest'anno la foto per vedere se tedesi
geneva di sapere quante ne avete
indovinato io ti ho battuto con io non
sono un giorno io mammeta stiamo facendo
scriveteci questi punti avete foto e
fatti sta per sembra di vedere altri
salvezza e ora vive sopra 4 cappelline
su cui cliccare per vedere i prossimi
video altri challenge video divertenti
slime cliccate su quella che preferite
si no